listen congrats on the movie uh I have a
lot of questions but I like throwing an
individual question and a curveball at
the beginning Sally my first question
for you is for you are you now a huge
Tom Brady fan
uh that's not a curveball
um it's just the wrong film
um for the next film but am I a huge Tom
Brady fan well having met him now
absolutely I of course I said to him at
the time I'm also a Rams fan because I'm
in La you know so oops
um he said that he was coming back
because he was going to make that he's
going to have a redo but it doesn't look
like that's going to happen either but
um he's he's just adorable bill I am a
huge fan of Legion and I loved the
series finale I love I love the entire
show I just want to know real quick were
you as happy as I was with how the
finale all came together
yeah
but I wish it hadn't finiled I was I
wish they were further that that story
could go
it was a great great gig and I'm glad to
see Amber midfunder in her stardom now
yeah for people that haven't seen that
series fantastic so um for both of you
you guys have both done such great work
um so many things to that people can
watch uh if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why
who are we talking to it could be anyone
I know the problem is it could be like a
15 year old or it could be a 50 year old
I mean what is the first thing I would
like them to watch
um
themselves probably watch yourself watch
where you step uh watch your life uh
care about things uh pay attention uh
read up I you know what I I wouldn't
have anything
to say I don't find myself like
promoting myself even though here I am
but I'm promoting a film
um so I I I don't know that I'd have
anything specific to to say to them a
young person
um I would I would I would wonder what
on Earth you have behind you I clearly
you are a you are a Marvel fan a I I
mean I I like a bunch of things I know
the monitor people that don't realize
you're probably looking at a very small
laptop screen so it is hard to see
behind me let's just say there's some
items there are some there are
definitely some items I'll switch to
bill then is there something that you'd
like people to watch I'll put it this
way as I get older I wish I could go
back and see we did a stage show called
Full Moon oh wow I don't even know I
wouldn't have counted however but I'd
love to sort of see have them come have
it be the beginning of that and come to
the theater and see you do that
I'd love I'd love to be able to go back
and see that and see how it compares to
my memory of doing it which is
interesting about this movie spoiler
alert we've been talking about what a
really fun bit of work it was it's you
know pretty heavy movie in some ways but
um coming to work is not always the case
but coming to work on this job was just
really enjoyable jumping into why I get
to talk to you one of the things that I
really love about the movie is that it
doesn't try to hollywoodize anything
it's just it's a real relationship about
two people and what they really went
through
um and you know the movies like this are
really hard to get made nowadays uh can
you sort of talk about that aspect uh
and why you wanted to do it
well I initially wanted to do it because
two of the people I have such great
respect for and regard for and I am
close to and I adore
um and have who are in this industry and
who have I I've had the great
opportunity to work with and that's uh
Michael Showalter the director and David
Marshall Grant the screenwriter
um they called me together and said they
had this film would I would I be in it
would I would I and I said absolutely
I'm I'm in I'm in it I'm Yours um David
Marshall Grant I worked with for five
years on a show called brothers and
sisters that that we did and
um and and Michael Showalter I did a
little movie called hello my name is
Doris and so they said great but would
you read it first before before you just
go over again and say and I said I'll
read it but I know I'll do it I will be
there and so luckily it is a wonderful
story about how hard it is to love
somebody
um for the duration and and and keep
that up and what that is whether it be
the parents to each other or to a child
or whether it's your partner uh love and
compassion and understanding
and endurance these are some key things
people have to remember in the world
today I think everything Sally says it's
it's an interesting movie in that it's
um it's so many different things but it
is not a three-month span rom-com story
it's a story of a long relationship
which culminated in marriage didn't
didn't begin as a marriage and
background characters supporting
characters is this long time marriage as
I told Sally I'm thinking back now my
first day of work I show up I'm working
with Sally I'm working with Showalter
I'm working with Jim Parsons who my
greatly admire I'm just meeting Ben
Aldridge and he's my son in the hospital
my first line is for Christ's sake
Marilyn so we're right into relationship
right away I'm not mistaken you guys
played a married couple like 18 years
ago or my right
20 years ago he keeps saying that stop
it just the other day right
what I mean it's amazing that you guys
got to do it again
um uh can you sort of talk about that
aspect because it's pretty crazy
it's it it's fabulous it was another
added part to this for me in that it was
Billy doing this we were on Broadway
together a number of years ago all right
I admit
um and it was a hard show to do uh Billy
had the brunt of it but it was still a
hard show and uh so when you do eight
performances a week from month after
month after month you kind of bond you
do Bond you do Bond I had a moment
however many years ago it was I'm down
stage sort of in ruminative mode Sally's
upstaged me throwing plates and I would
Revel in watching the audience's eyes on
her
they couldn't believe what she was doing
and yeah to be we were able to hit the
road running as husband and wife I'm
always listen I love talking to actors
and how they actually get ready for a
performance um can you sort of talk a
little bit about uh actually I'm gonna
switch it I like knowing about um like a
big emotional scene so if you have
something like a big scene coming up uh
how do you like to prepare for something
like that well you know the different
they're different scenes and different
ways I mean certainly this scene what
our the requirements were uh for Bill in
in May I I ca I can't speak for him but
I I venture to say he's going to say
exactly the same thing that I do is I
didn't have to prepare at all I didn't
know preparation as a matter of fact I
had to stay away from it as long as I
could
um because I have three sons
um and even though I did not see any of
my sons as kit I just know you put
yourself in that emotional Arena
uh and we got to improv a little bit
with with what what we did and what we
said because it's it's Michael Showalter
and he allows that space but uh for me I
had to stay away I I it was best not to
prepare
um very much at all
um because I would have then left it in
wherever that preparation was was
happening it it was so
um you know Vivid because of what it's
about to these these two parents so
for me it was just you know step in and
and try to maintain yes
just try to maintain I like Sally I'm
the proud parent of a proud young gay
man and uh and you're telling the story
of
something that happens to your son it
just kind of tells itself and you hang
on for dear life and that note I gotta
stop I'm just gonna say congrats and I
wish you guys nothing but the best
thank you so much